Good morning J-, good morning, good morning,
good morning John I, good morning, good morning
John, good morning John I'm, good morning
John I'm back home and I missed, good morning
John I'm back home and I'm.
Good morning John it's Sunday. I'm back home
and I missed you so much that I was watching
our video that we did together, and I noticed
how much funny stuff there was that didn't
get to go in the video. So I'm making a special
Sunday video in which all I'm doing is putting,
ah, the funny parts that we didn't put in,
into this video and it's pretty short, but
I enjoy it and I hope you enjoy it and that's
all I'm gonna do. John, I'll see you tomorrow.
JOHN: Alright, let's just record for twenty
minutes. Everything we are about to say shall
be funny.
HANK: We need to come in and out
JOHN: In! Out! AAh!
HANK: We're on rocking chairs.
JOHN: Today's video comes to you in three
parts. Part one...
HANK: An announcement. Part two...
JOHN: A daaah I'm not ready!
For years nerdfighteria has been taking over,
did you just burp?
HANK: No, but I'm going to cut you off so
that I can say that part.
JOHN: Ok, Yea, fine.
We were just talking to Youtube on the telephone.
They were like, "Hey!" and then, yeah. That's
actually our whole conversation.
HANK: Hey!
JOHN: Hey! What's going on Youtube? No yeah,
we just, we were talking to Youtube, no big
deal.
All of you will make videos on December 18th.
Please door, you're ruining everything!
Gah, this is my video now!
HANK: And we will be announcing more things
in the future so give you(incoherent babble).
JOHN: That was very eloquent at the end particularly
I'm-- I'm moved.
And for those of you who don't know what the
project for awesome--and for those of you
who don't know what the project for awesome
is, we're putting videos--and for those of
you who don't know what the project for awesome--and
for those of you who don't know what--and
for those of you who don't know much about
the project for--and for those of you--and
for those of you who don't know what the project
for awesome is--GAH I've said this 45 times!
HANK: Part two! A challenge!
JOHN: We will allow you to challenge us to
do something horrible.
HANK: And when he says 'us'...I think he just
means 'him'.
JOHN: Is that true?!
HANK: I'll do something horrible, too.
JOHN: I'll do something MORE horrible.
HANK: It's true. You always do something more
horrible.
JOHN: I love the horrible things! I'm a masochist.
HANK: Part three, the final announcement--part
three, the final ama--part three, the final
amou--hehe
JOHN: HAHAHA I'm gonna make--actually, I'm
just gonna
HANK: Just do an outtakes video
JOHN: It's all gonna be outtakes.
JOHN: In some ways, I feel like I invented
the giant squid of anger so that Vondell could
make that image.
Okay so quick recap!
HANK: dftba.com/sale for your..bbhbh..
JOHN: Okay so quick recap!
HANK: dftba.com for your tshirt needs
JOHN: <shakes head> Wrong.
<both laugh>
JOHN: We've been doing this for four years.
You're not on the screen right now...
HANK: I know I don't know how
JOHN: Uh..I think I just keep like pushing
you out. Like 'THE FRAME IS MIIINE!'
Um...alright. So quick recap!
HANK: dftba.com/sale for your tshirt needs.
JOHN: Uh...moonpies? No. Dammit!
HANK: Pies?!
JOHN: Ohhh....moonpies are a real thing in
the South!
HANK: John I'll see you sometime.
JOHN: I mean like just as soon as you turn
off the camera we'll probably continue to
see each other.
HANK: John I see you right now!
JOHN: Bahahaha!
HANK: I see you!
JOHN: I know. I feel like you see me.
Last night Hank and Katherine were being their
typical sort of uh...lefty mamby pamby selves,
and Katherine was like 'I wanna thank the
fish,' and then my wife was like 'I see you,
fish...'
HAHAHA That's the best joke ever!!
DFTBA Nerdfighteria!
HANK: We'll see you on Monday.
JOHN: We'll see you on Monday. We can't--
HANK: He'll see you on Monday.
JOHN: I'll see you on Monday.
<they high five>
JOHN: We should re-do that last part.